for every Batman the Animated Series out
there there's a show that hasn't exactly
stood the test of time
these 90's cartoons might have been part
of your regular lineup back in the day
but you probably shouldn't schedule a
binge watching session anytime soon
there was a period in the 80s and 90s
where a ton of teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles ripoffs permeated the zeitgeist
from battletoads to biker mice from mars
plenty of creators tried to replicate
the formula of taking animals and
turning them into buff anthropomorphic
warriors going somewhere boys one of the
most egregious examples of the trend was
street sharks which ran from 1994 to
1997
the premise is absurdly simple and
simply absurd for regular American
genius teenager brothers are forcibly
transformed into humanoid fish courtesy
of a gene slammer
thus the titular street sharks are born
and they spend their days battling
monsters in the streets of fission city
the whole thing feels like one of those
ideas that was designed to sell toys
more than actually create an enjoyable
television series that's because well it
was
[Music]
[Applause]
the series probably had some fans
considering it lasted for three seasons
but street sharks never got out of a
certain shell-shaped shadow so if you're
going to revisit a series about buff
animals you're better off sticking with
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles Ironman is
now a household name thanks to his
prevalence in movie theaters over the
last decade starting with the 2008
blockbuster Tony Stark went on to become
the central figure of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but before Robert
Downey jr. made the character a
household name most people only knew
Iron Man from his short-lived and
critically panned cartoon series from
the 90s after the success of the x-men
cartoon Marvel was wanting to expand
their lineup the result was the Marvel
action hour which aired shows such as
Iron Man and Fantastic Four but in case
you were thinking of looking more into
Iron Man's origins there's no reason to
bother with this show the storylines are
overly dramatic and confusing with
little explanation given for why
characters are in certain situations
also Tony Stark has a terrible mullet
when you see it you just can't pay
attention to anything else on screen
everybody who grew up in the 90s knows
Doug the series follows a boy entering
the sixth grade and along the way he
goes through everything regular kids go
through he has a bully he has to
regularly contend with and he develops
feelings for the cute girl in his class
but while having something kids can
relate to is commendable the show is
pretty bland in hindsight granted the
series tries to take advantage of its
cartoon medium by showing Doug's vivid
imagination where he assumes the role of
secret agents and other cool guys but
that's about it as far as creativity
goes sure Doug was a nice reprieve among
the rest of Nickelodeon's programming
but if you watch it now you're likely to
be bored out of your mind the
Transformers franchise has been
incredibly lucrative over the years
while the original series has held up in
many fans eyes there have been various
spin-offs that have tried to capitalize
on that success to varying degrees one
of these is transformers beast wars
which well isn't perfect
[Music]
watching it today the biggest problem
with the series is clearly the CG
animation it was a new technique in the
90s when the show first aired and a lot
of viewers probably saw the show as
state of the art on one hand it's
understandable that these dwarfs doesn't
look great today on the other hand there
are other transformers cartoons that
essentially feature the same stories
with better visuals there was a point in
time when Mortal Kombat dominated
arcades across the United States the
gory fighting caught on with players of
all ages and the video game even lent
itself to a feature-length film however
when the creators tried to follow up
that success with Mortal Kombat
defenders of the realm it just didn't
work at all for starters the cartoon
series featured characters that were in
Mortal Kombat 3 which was noteworthy for
leaving out several popular characters
from earlier in the series
additionally the show was geared toward
young children so it couldn't be
anywhere near as violent as the games
much has changed since the last Mortal
Kombat tournament granted this was all
part of a trend in the 90s when studios
took r-rated properties and turned them
into children's cartoons just look at
Robocop and toxic crusaders hi little
fella why you're a cute little blob just
like most of those defenders of the
realm didn't work for kids or adults
released in 1994 the mask was an
incredibly popular movie that followed
Jim Carrey as a timid banker named
stanley ipkiss who would turn into a
larger-than-life trickster at night
after donning a magical mask
one year later Hollywood tried to
capture lightning in a bottle twice by
producing an animated series about the
character it makes sense that people
still love the cinematic version of the
mask as Jim Carrey is a lot of fun to
watch and incredibly funny the movie
also works because it's only 101 minutes
in length which is just about enough
time to not get sick of Carrey shtick
that's not the case with 54 episodes of
this animated series where it kiss
quickly gets too annoying to bear but
hey it's still better than son of the
mask check out one of our newest videos
right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite shows are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
you